Our next question was about external API’s
and relying on them and the dangers and pit falls of that.
For example, for Hipmunk, you parse Amtrak's website
and what if they redesign that, how screwed are you?
Sure. Well, it’s true.
If Amtrak changes their website, our parsing of Amtrak also
breaks and that’s basically how it goes.
It’s not really a big deal, that’s just kind the way it goes.
The harder decision you have to make there is how you want to
actually parse the website for websites that don't have an API
or websites whose API is so bad, you’d rather just script the HTML.
You can do it by hand. I showed you some regular expression examples in the lecture.
Those work if the website isn't changing very often.
Basically whatever works--parsing HTML is really tough because HTML is often invalid
and malformed and all those sort of issues, so basically play whatever works and--
Yeah. >>And-- >>Just do what you can.
Yeah. Things break and then you fix on them and that’s how it goes. >>Okay. Great.